منذر اليوم نحنا انا واحد من الناس مثل ما
انت ضيف على صباح العربيه انا ايضا اضيف
في صباح العربيه ولكن هذه المره لمحاورتك
ايضا مليون منذر رياحنا ايش وداك ليبيا
الناس تقول والله خطر وانت رايح تصور
خريبي ليش شو اللي دفعك
مقاومه
بمهلتنا همم
باحس انه من واجبنا ان نقدم نقدم شيء همم
في ظل الاشياء اللي قدمه
ليبيا جميله لا تستحق للجمال
وحسيت واجب انه الفنان يحارب بمادته وكنت
مبسوط جدا
من حيث تجربه العظيمه جدا اييه ورجعت
منتصرا من ليبيا عشان اهل ليبيا قدموا عمل
رائع بيننا فيه انجازات
لانه الفيلم الثاني فقط بعد عمر المختار
يكون الانتاج الليبي 100%
يعني ان شاء الله كمان يتقدم في عده
مهرجانات يقدم الفيلم الاول باذن الله في
المهرجانات العالميه
دائما نحن ننتمي الى السلاح ننتمي الى
الكلمه ولكن هم اجبرونا
متخلفين والدواعش
حكايه انسانيه
بطوله مجموعه كبيره من النجوم كلنا
متحمسين
جداول
بمشروع بناء من جوانب مختلفه واظن نحن بس
احسن من الشهداء اللي قدمه في سبيل الوطن
طب منذر انا صوتي رايح اليوم ضليتني اترجى
طول البرنامج عادي لا يقعد معايا بس عادل
بس مع انه منذر موجود قاعد بضيف غالي
وعزيز ليحاورك مش عارف
اول مره يعني كنا بتغدينا مع بعض وما عاد
راح قال انا راجع الى دبي وما رجع على
فكره
الفيلم الحاره حصل جوائز مهمه لكن اثار
الجدل
والله يا استاذتي الجدل يثار عندما تقدم
الحقيقه
احنا صرنا نقدم اشياء ما تشبهناش
فاظن الان
لازم تقدمير الحقيقي
ليش ليش الناس تعترض
مش هو الفن مراه المجتمع
يعكس كل ما يحدث
انا ممكن اقدم حدوثه الاسلاميه
لا انا قدمت ادوار كثير بحب
[ضحك]
لا انا بحب اقدم الشيء المختلف شوفي مهما
كان انت
موجود في الدراسه
في كل التاسيس يعني ولكن شو الاسلوب
في الموضوع مش موضوع انك بلعب او دور خير
في موبايل
بالنسبه
اشياء مختلفه جدا انا باحب اكون محادد نعم
نعم
منظر اليوم البعض ايضا ينتقد بانه ما كان
ممنوعا في السابق اصبح يستسهله الممثلون
اليوم بانه الالفاظ المواقف الايماءات
الحركات حتى وان كانت في بعض الاحيان تخدم
الدور او حتى تخرج ابعد من الدول
في المدينه النبيله يعني بكل العالم
[موسيقى]
بتسمعه في كل مكان اذا انا بدي اقدمه بشكل
وخاف من طريقه الاداء والناس ما راح تصدق
ههه
اولاد يكون مثلا حتى لو كان
ما يحضر الفيلم ولا احد
يدفع الفلوس ههه
[ضحك]
طيب منذر شو اقرب الاعمال لقلب منذر
عملت مسلسل ماذا لو كنت مريض السرطان
بموت
فانا يعني هو كانه صار يا صديقي
كلمتين بكلمتين لبعض يتقبلها يمكن يكون
هذا الفيلم ياتي هذا الفضل فيلم لبناني
لكن اردني لا ليش
انه ههه
طيب كفو كفو شكرا